welcome back okay so in the last time we
developed the eigen system realization
algorithm it really is an algorithm it's
data-driven you collect data you build a
matrix you take the SVD and you get a
model we're gonna code this up next
we're gonna you know we're gonna program
this up and see how it works there's a
big code that does all of these steps
and keeps track of the sizes of
everything and P's and Q's and you know
you your parents always told you to mind
your P's and Q's well that's what we're
talking about here so this is connected
to balanced model reduction it turns out
that based on a symmetry of the Hankel
matrix these are inherently balanced
models if you collect enough data
if you collect this long enough that all
of the tails of this die out these will
be balanced models the graeme ins will
be approximately equal in diagonal in
these coordinates which is really cool
there's a connection to balance proper
orthogonal decomposition and balance
truncation you can basically take all of
this data driven stuff and write it in
terms of direct snapshot C and adjoint
snapshots oh and you can go through the
math and figure out that it's the same
but there's a more concrete connection
to balanced p OD is what if I have full
state measurements right so we assumed
that there's some underlying linear
system with some true full state X that
we probably can't measure but we can
just measure input and output data and
we're trying to approximate those
dynamics in terms of some proxy state X
tilde that's low dimensional but what if
I actually have like real data you know
I do my I'm always gonna do an airfoil
because that's what I can draw I
actually have my full simulation and I
can get the movie of this thing evolving
in time that's my full state so what if
I actually had in addition to the
measurements let's say in this case
let's say Y is a pressure measurement on
the wing and I have that time series and
I want to build a model that I can use
for an online flight controller where I
will
we have this pressure measurement that's
great this all works but what if when I
was building that model I did this in a
laboratory or in a simulation and I
actually did have access in that one
time I had access to the entire full
state measurement X as it evolved in
time XK okay I want to make this very
clear I want to build a model that I can
use in the field so I'm only gonna in
the field I'm only going to have this
one pressure measurement so I still want
Y to be that pressure measurement I
still want a reduced order model to do
control on so I'm gonna build that model
but maybe when I was building this model
I did this in a laboratory or in a
simulation where I actually had access
to X so I'm gonna use the model in the
field where I only have Y but in my
laboratory I had access to met 2x I
spent a lot of money a lot of time a lot
of resources and I got X so if I can
measure the full state X then in
addition to all of this impulse response
data I also have curly C which was you
know if I wrote down my system matrix it
was B a B a squared B dot dot or really
it's just X 1 X 2 X 3 dot dot the
measurements of my state of my system X
as they evolve in time I don't actually
need these matrices I can just measure
my state as it evolved and don't see if
I had this remember I said that the the
model here is kind of uninterpretable
there's this funny hidden state X tilde
it's this latent set of variables you
need to describe the dynamics well if I
have access to the full state
measurements I can get an interpretable
model what I can do is I can essentially
say those SCI modes these are might my
modes from balance truncation are going
to equal curly C times V tilde times
Sigma tilde minus 1/2 ok so if I had
access to this data this is very
expensive data to get sometimes but
maybe I can do this in one time in a
laboratory I can take these reduced
order of ease and sigmaz and I can build
these full state modes every column of
SCI is the size of a neck
it's a big vector that in this case
would be a flow field picture okay every
column of this is a mode and each of
these modes is what those little X tilde
states mean so X tilde had let's say
three modes X 1 tilde X 2 tilde X 3
tilde there were three hidden States
let's say then this would have three
columns and that first column would be a
flow field picture and this is the
amplitude of that mode it's how much of
that mode is on at that given time X 2
tilde would correspond to the second
column that would be another picture of
a flow field and X 3 tilde would
correspond to the third column which
would be another flow field picture so
this allows me to get like movies of
what my reduced order system is doing I
can in fact I can approximate the full
high dimensional X is approximately now
sy times my reduced state so this allows
me to if I have access to full data in
training it allows me to build a reduced
order model and interpret what that
reduced state means in terms of the the
big full state in this case I've fluid I
get a full movie of my a reduced order
model and so this is really how BPO D is
connected to ER a is in the case that
you have full state measurements then
these models really do become equivalent
this really is exactly the sy matrix
that you would get from BP OD and so on
and so forth so very useful you can
build reduce order models just from
inputs to outputs but if you happen to
be lucky or or careful and you can build
this full state measurements in the
laboratory you can then get much more
interpretable er a models really cool
very useful next time we're going to
talk about what happens if I can't do a
direct impulse response what if I can't
kick the system cleanly and instead I
have to give it some pseudo-random
forcing how could I back out the impulse
response okay thank you